All right. Welcome back to my channel today.
We are going to code some JavaScript because it's been a long time.
I haven't been coding, you know,
cause I work as a data scientist and by data scientists, I mean a data analyst,
but you know,
we call it data scientists at Silicon Valley because we get to get paid more.
If we're called data scientists.
So pretty much any 12 year old can actually do my job,
but we still get paid a ton to do it.
Oh wait. Just a minute.
So this video is sponsored by Wix code and I'll talk about this right now.
So you guys know what Wix is, right?
The website that allows you to make sunning websites. Well,
now they have a Wix code,
which allows us coders to tinker with the backend so that we can do so much
more. So I could finally do so much more by adding a database,
adding user forms and using JavaScript and their API.
So I could finally make interactive websites. So check this out.
I just made a database right here and then on my home page,
I connected to the dataset. So now whenever someone writes me a message,
it pops up right here. Once I finished this website,
I'm going to have a personal wall so I can display all the awesome messages and
support that you guys gave me right here on this website.
So click on the link on the description to get started with your website today.
Anyways, I really missed coding. So if you missed part one and part two,
you should go check that out,
but I'll just give you a quick summary of what I'm building previously on
cookies code in JavaScript. Never shared it.
I wanted to make an app where you can synchronize watching YouTube between your
friends. So I used it YouTube API to create a player.
Then I also made a play and pause button so that I could send custom requests
back to the server so that I could synchronize between the players.
All right. Lego. My echo, my [inaudible] come on. I turn.
Okay. All right.
Let's take a break. All right.
So there's something important that I want to talk about. Um,
a lot of people have mentioned that I opened the banana. It's not open.
It's peel you idiot that I opened the banana wrongly. Oh,
guess what? You're wrong? Oh, well guess what? Your English is wrong
because that's how monkeys open it. Okay. You have to pinch it from here.
Not from here. Like if I want to open the Oh crap. Okay.
That was a lot easier than I thought, but usually it's really hard,
especially if it's not right. It's like, Oh my God. It's so hard to open it.
Here's how you actually peel a banana. Wow. Good job.
You finally used the word peel. You just pinch it right here.
There you go. It's so much easier. Okay.
See, see how much effort it took. It took so much effort.
And now imagine if you want to, okay.
Okay. Imagine if you want to pass the banana to someone else. Pass it to me now.
Oh, no.
Like how the hell am I supposed to hold it? All right. Now try this one. Wow.
It's like, if there's a, can you hold it properly? I'm going to do it again. Oh,
this is so hard. Totally like this. man. Get one, two, three. Okay.
Wow. Thank you. Look at that. Good thing. There's an end. Good thing.
I could hold the tail. It makes it so much easier to pass a banana around.
So there you have it. That's really important.
Okay.
All right. Okay. Okay. All right. Let's code for real now,
Man. You know what I realized?
There are so many different ways of sitting and I feel like each way,
determines your personality a little bit. Let me tell you what I,
I mean the super straight up stance, super ergonomic,
their chest is popping elbows, aligned desks. I hate those people.
They're so nice to you and perfect. They're probably secretly a serial killer.
No one is that ergonomic. And I do not believe that's comfortable at all.
Now that's the stance.
I believe in perfectly snug optimal for coding efficiently.
I think that's being true to yourself.
And then there's some people that never wear shoes for some reason.
And they love to put their feet up.
It's like they watch too much Def note or something and they think they're
quirky and totally random. And then there's this guy who's super stressed,
keeps pulling his hair, you know,
swears from time to time and he just looks miserable.
And then we got this guy who's mouth is always open, like 24, seven.
He's probably a gamer or something. And just so concentrated. But come on, man.
Just close your mouth. Okay. Okay. Okay.
For real now let's start coding for real. All right. So let's go to the,
to the web app. Oh, oops. I did not start it in PM. Start.
All right. Great. Great. We have it on here.
So the first thing we're going to do is we're going to add a click event on all
of these buttons, like for example, play and stop. So right now,
if you click these, you know, it doesn't really do anything.
But what we want to do is that each time we click the play or the pause button,
we send it to the server.
So the server could send it to everyone that's logged in. All right,
let's do that.
All right, cool. So now that we've got the buttons working,
we're going to send this message back to the server,
but first the server has received it.
[Inaudible].
Just wait a minute. You know, it takes me some time to read.
Okay, got it. Got it.
And then now the front end, when you receive these messages,
you have to act on it. So for example, if you receive a play request,
I'm going to play my video. If you receive a pause request,
I'm going to pause my video. Let's do that.
[Inaudible].
All right. So let's check my Twitter. All right. Thank you, Jake.
For the support. Really, really appreciate it.
And then also we have one question by Samsung.
What tools do you use for data visualization? For me,
I use mostly Tableau and Excel, so it's super easy to use.
I don't even have to write code for it. So. All right.
Thanks for watching this video. If you like it,
don't forget to like and subscribe and yes. See you later.
This video is.
Sponsored by Wix code. Wow. I didn't expect that.
[Inaudible].
You are like, how are you related to, uh, we're friends? Are we? Yes.
And Al so, I mean, I kind of have to also decide about your career.
If you're going to get promoted or fired,
if you want him to get promoted or fired, one likes were fired.